ومعنا من كيف العقيد رومان
القومي والاستخبارات في البرلمان
الاوكراني اهلا وسهلا بك سيد كوستانجو
هل نحن عمليا في هدنا الان
ليس بيننا وبين روسيا ولن نتفق عن اي هدنا
بل هم يستمروا بقصف مواقعنا ونحن نستمر في
الدفاع ونقوم بالرد بضربات ضد العدو ليس
لدينا اي هدنا مع العدو اذا اعتبرناها
هدنا هل كنتم اول المبادرين بخلقها كما
تقول موسكو على الاقل
صور من وجهه نظر روسيا ممكن ان نعتقد باي
شيء لكن اننا نقدنا هدنا لم ننقد شيء من
روسيا من تجتاح اراضنا وتقصف المدنيين
وتقتل المواطنين الاوكراني والان تحاول ان
تجد غطاء في الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه التي
باركت قتل المدنيين الاوكرانيين وايه
يتكلمون عنهن لا نحتاج الى الهدنه نحتاج
الى النصر هل موقفكم من الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه التي خذلتكم كما تقول كيف هو
الذي يفسر عدم احترام هذه الهدنه او عدم
النظر فيها اصلا
توم وجيري سؤال هنا
في ان
روسيا تستخدم وتستغل الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه
التي تخضع للكريم لين وباركت قتل المدنيين
الاخرانيين والكنيسه التي تحاول دعت الصف
الاوكراني في المجتمع الاوكراني
ويحاول ان يقولوا يحاول ان يضغطوا على
المؤمنين والمتدينين في اوكرانيا ان الشعب
الاوكرانيا يرى جيدا اثر هذه الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه الروسيه التي تبارك الاوكراني
لذلك هذه الخطوه هي عباره عن حرب اعلاميه
ودعائيه
كيف ممكن ان نؤمن
بيهدنا في وقت تقوم به القوات الروسيه
بقصف وقتل المدنيين كان لدينا ال
اعياد الميلاد في ال 25 من ديسمبر واراس
السنه وكانوا يقصفون اثناء الاعياد
المدنيين ويقتلون الاطفال والنساء عن اي
كنيسه ممكن ان نتحدث هنا ولكن الا يوجد في
اوكرانيا من يحتفل باعياد الميلاد في
السابع من يناير
وبالتالي قد يكون هو يرغب في التقاط
الانفاس ولو قليلا
عات او عقيده على المواطنين ولكن علينا ان
نقول ان
الاعياد ليس لها اي اثر على العمليات
العسكريه ولا تؤثر على علاقه بالمحتل
وكل يوم بالنسبه لنا مهم حتى نتقرب للنصر
لذلك الهدنه او الاعلان عن الهدنه هي جزء
من معركه
الروسيه وليس هناك اي معنى اخر في هذا
الهدنه ممكن يعلن بها في القنوات الدعائيه
التابعه للعدو انا كنت اليوم على الجبهات
واريد ان اقول ان اطلاق تبادل اطلاق النار
مستمر ولم يمارس هذه الهدنه هو همم صفارات
الانذار تستمر في جميع المناطق الاوكرانيه
ونحن نرى التهديدات من
البيلاروسيه لذلك عن اي هدنه هنا ممكن ان
نتحدث نحن لا نشعر به ولا نؤمن بهذا نحن
نستمر بالدفاع عن المدنيين ونستمر بالحرب
والدفاع عن حريهنا ان هذه الهدنه هي مجرد
لعبه اعلاميه ليس اكثر نستمر بالمعارك
العسكريه حتى الان
شكرا جزيلا